[Music]
on this Tuesday night Hockey Canada
Executives get defensive to scapegoat
hockey as a centerpiece for toxic
culture is in my opinion
counterproductive the grilling they got
over secret slush funds to settle sex
abuse lawsuits the players walked away
with no consequences calls grow louder
for a civilian Disaster Response Force
instead of relying on the Canadian
military standing up for women's rights
and against Iran's regime the revolution
is unfolding the movement is gaining
momentum where is it headed and she was
a coal miner's daughter and the queen of
country music
tall girl the legacy of the legendary
Loretta Lynn
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin tonight with Hockey Canada an
organization that was already under
intense scrutiny for its handling of
multiple sexual assault allegations
today the scrutiny got even more intense
MPS of all political Stripes grilled the
senior leadership team at Hockey Canada
about using non-disclosure agreements to
silence abuse victims and secret slush
funds to settle multi-million dollar
lawsuits
Hockey Canada is saying we'll pay we'll
pay we'll make it go away and the
players can just continue and no one
will ever hear any further details do
you understand why it looks to the
general public like Hockey Canada is
condoning that behavior I understand
there is a perspective out there and and
I I do with with great respect disagree
with it we we decided to resolve the
matter in a way that was
um trauma-centered victim-centered or
complainant centered and at the same
time we've got an investigation that's
ongoing
it was combative it was tense the
executives repeatedly defended their
record and said nothing needs to change
Abigail Beeman has our top story tonight
our board does not share the view that
Hockey Canada should be making more
leadership changes at this time from the
opening statement through two hours of
testimony defense defense defense
scapegoat hockey as a centerpiece for
toxic culture is in my opinion
counterproductive to scapegoat the
organization at the center of criticism
over its handling of sexual assault
particularly allegations of group sex
assault by some players in 2018 tried to
paint itself as the victim substantial
misinformation and an unduly cynical
attacks Hockey Canada has an excellent
reputation I do not fault Senior
Management or the board with respect to
the way the 2018 sexual assault incident
was handled it's important not to be
tone deaf in a deeply politicized
committee climate all political parties
were on the same page the answers have
just not been forthcoming and the
transparency has not been present and
you have said no we are going to protect
the leader we are going to keep the
leader and somehow magically still
change culture filter
is that correct
no I'm sorry respectfully I disagree
with that the Globe and Mail reported
there was a second undisclosed fund to
cover sexual assault claims and other
lawsuits paid by player registration
fees while the interim chair referenced
misinformation she didn't explain the
contradictions that it's inaccurate to
say that the participants Legacy trust
fund was used to settle sexual assault
claims they're seeing also that it's not
used for sexual assault but it says it
very in the very wording of his
affidavit that this is one of the
purposes of the fund so I don't think
she acquitted herself very well on that
one the organization's Federal funding
Frozen the minister of sports says the
government will look as far back as 2016
to make sure no public funds were used
in the settlement at this point with the
current leadership
I've I don't have hope that there that
they have the capacity to renew
themselves from within she's calling on
provincial voting members of Hockey
Canada to push for change at the top
Abigail Beeman Global News
Ottawa in the United States members of
the women's national soccer team are
demanding immediate changes after a
skating report detailed systemic verbal
emotional and sexual misconduct within
the country's top women's soccer league
the highly anticipated report found the
abuse and misconduct spent multiple
teams coaches and victims it also
details what it calls a deeper culture
in women's soccer including youth
leagues that normalizes abuse and blurs
the boundaries between coaches and
players a lengthy list of
recommendations include making the
public aware of suspended individuals
and raises the question of disciplining
team owners
for the third straight year
participation has given Canadian kids a
failing grade for overall physical
activity screen time and sleep habits in
its latest report the organization says
already low activity levels for kids and
teens plunged even further largely
because of Public Health restrictions
physical activity went from a d Plus in
2020 to a d this year and while screen
time grades dropped from a d to an F
participation does say that's worrisome
but expects those grades to rise now
that pandemic restrictions are lifted
in Atlantic Canada the Prime Minister
backed up last week's promise to help
people recover from Hurricane Fiona
Justin Trudeau was in Nova Scotia today
announcing hundreds of millions of
dollars in Aid Ross Lord reports
for the second time since Fiona
devastated Atlanta Canada the prime
minister is promising government
assistance with rebuilding the federal
government is announcing the new 300
million dollar hurricane Fiona Recovery
Fund he first prime minister Trudeau
says the money will be used for things
like repairing fishing wars and getting
damaged businesses back on their feet
the Atlantic Canada opportunities agency
will administer the program although
some details are still being finalized
with respect to the criteria as well we
still have some details that need to be
worked out but I can tell you that the
money is going to be rolling out very
quickly because we recognize there are
serious needs on the ground and we want
to be there for Canadians the government
says the fund is meant for people who
are not covered by existing programs
what it can't do is restore power to
people who've been without it for day
after day after day you feel cut off you
feel lonely Bob Bentley is on day 11 in
the dark along with thousands of other
Pei residents no internet no TV no
freezer no cooking it's it's been it's
been rough
we uh we'd rather have a
some semblance of order it's unclear how
or if they'd qualify for assistance
under the new federal fund there was
there was my house as for people who are
uninsured or underinsured like many in
the port of ask Newfoundland area whose
homes were destroyed the government
promises they won't be forgotten a
commitment welcomed by the town's mayor
there was a fear on the days where all
this was going well you know will I be
left out uh you know it's not that I
wouldn't carry insurance I just had to
make a choice between insurance or
putting food on the table for my
children
the Prime Minister insists the money
will not be bogged down in bureaucracy
because the growing frequency of natural
disasters has forced the government to
become much better at rolling out
assistance Ross Lord Global News Halifax
if the Canadian Red Cross says the
country needs to be better prepared for
natural disasters and can't only rely on
the military testifying on Parliament
Hill Conrad sovay says climate-related
disasters are becoming more common and
emergency response operations are
placing and increasing strain on
governments the military and groups like
The Red Cross sovay recommends the
creation of a civilian Disaster Response
Force
and while the Canadian Armed Forces have
always been there to help in times of
disaster they must remain the force of
Last Resort and should not be the only
permanent National surge capacity in
times of emergencies
there are more than 700 Canadian
military personnel in Atlantic Canada
helping with the cleanup from Hurricane
Fiona but thousands of customers are
still without power
in Florida more than 1500 American Red
Cross volunteers are working around the
clock to help people in the aftermath of
hurricane Ian emergency aid centers are
in full swing people are lining up for
food and other Basics it's been nearly a
week since the category 4 storm
obliterated thousands of homes and
businesses in Florida at least 106
people are now confirmed to have died
and more than 2 thousand people have
been rescued the search though is still
going on as Jackson prosco reports
so much of Florida is unrecognizable
like Coastal Sanibel Island completely
cut off from the mainland hundreds of
people rode out the storm here
500 have since been airlifted to safety
Lacey McClary recorded the storm as it
tore through her home on the island I
thought this we need to make peace this
may be the time but God please just
saved all of us on nearby Pine Island
the storm surge took what the wind
didn't
residents are only now finding their way
to safety it was a nightmare really I
don't know how we would survived
no I didn't think we were
Statewide there's a desperate rush to
rescue people and distribute supplies
as search and rescue crews continue to
comb through shattered homes and endless
debris lifting up houses lifting up
Rubble listening sending dogs in so what
they're trying to do is to find the
survivors there are also growing
questions about whether mandatory
evacuation orders came too late many
residents stayed put believing earlier
forecasts that Ian would strike further
north we got that message out at the
right time
now whether people listen to it we can't
force people out of their homes this
generational disaster may be among the
deadliest and most expensive in Florida
history we lost everything
amidst the ruins of shattered lives
there are people who still refuse to
leave
after losing everything they own they
can't bear the thought of losing the
place they call home
Jackson prosco Global News
Quebec Premier Francois Lego got back to
work today after winning an even bigger
majority in last night's provincial
election
[Music]
Suburban writings but was unable to
connect with many diverse voters in
Montreal Lago says his focus is on
protecting the French language and that
he won't reopen the discussion over
electoral reform
mounting Defiance coming up protests
against the Iranian regime are massive
what difference will they make
protests against the regime in Iran
continue in that country despite a
brutal Crackdown and they're gaining
momentum in other countries too
including Canada the death of Masa amini
last month has set off a powerful
movement against the oppressive regime
into Iran a past protests have ended
with no change Heather York's West looks
at what people are hoping for this time
the chaotic scenes of violence and
Terror are difficult to watch there are
countless people dead there's countless
examples of them being taken away with
with bags over their heads
foreign
God knows what's going to happen to
these kids
young people protesting Iran's
government have become Targets in recent
days rights groups estimate more than
130 people have died as the country
tries to gain control of a protest
movement that just continues to grow it
was two and a half weeks ago that the
death of 22 year old Masa amini sparked
a collective rage towards Iran's regime
but just as they've done in the past
Iran's leaders have responded with
brutality just uh two days ago Security
Forces surrounded Iran's leading
University
basically locking students down on
campus and then arrested students while
also shooting live ammunition Canada
announced new sanctions against Iran
Monday with the promise of more action
to come several European countries are
pushing the EU to do the same I am
obviously worried deeply worried about
my own family members about you know
people from you know my country of birth
um but at the same time there is a
certain degree of exhilaration at the
idea that uh these protests are gaining
momentum and the revolution is unfolding
Boyd by the support of Iran's diaspora
worldwide in Canada rallies have drawn
tens of thousands to the streets
standing in solidarity with those who
continue to put their lives on the line
who after 40 Years of Oppression are now
refusing to back down
other Europe's West Global News Calgary
the U.S and South Korea have fired four
ground-to-ground missiles during joint
military drills a response to North
Korea launching a ballistic missile over
Japanese territory
Japan briefly activated its emergency
alert system when the missile flew over
Hokkaido it ended up Landing in the sea
North Korea last fired a missile over
Japan five years ago but has upped its
military its missile testing recently in
response it says to the drills being
carried out by the U.S and South Korea
Japan calls the latest missile launch a
threat to Regional security
Ukrainian forces are making rapid
progress on two fronts recapturing
territory in the country's South and
Northeast those advances follow the
recapture of a key rail Hub of Lehman on
Saturday Ukrainian soldiers now taking
stock of a large number of Russian
vehicles and ammunition that was left
behind by the retreating Russian forces
Ukrainian President Vladimir zielinski
says the Ukrainian flag is now flying
again over hundreds of communities in
the Don bass donets and harkiv regions
at the same time the first Russian
troops called up during the recent
mobilization have begun arriving in
Ukraine after just a handful of days of
training
the European Union is moving ahead with
plans to standardize all phone chargers
the new rule is a world first it will
introduce a single USB charging point
for mobile phones tablets cameras and
other devices by 2024 the measure is
expected to affect iPhone maker Apple
more than its Rivals e-lawmakers
overwhelmingly approved the change it
was prompted by complaints from iPhone
and Android users about having to switch
to different chargers for their devices
forgotten tragedies ahead the Grim
reminder of the thousands of indigenous
women who never came home
three years after the release of the
final report of the national inquiry
into missing and murdered indigenous
women and girls groups from all across
the country say not enough is being done
to prevent further tragedies in Toronto
a huge and heartbreaking newspaper
called cover stories tells the
individual stories of four thousand
Mothers Daughters and sisters who never
came home as Anita garcha reports the
size of that newspaper is meant to be
shocking and to put the focus on the
ongoing lack of action to protect
indigenous women and girls each woman
deserved their own cover story meant to
finally give them the attention
warranted this newspaper featuring 4 000
cover stories honors the lives of
missing and murdered indigenous women
girls and two-spirit people we also
wanted to define the magnitude in the
physical paper itself the paper weighs
about 25 pounds and that really
demonstrates that if you capture the
true story of of each indigenous woman
who has been missing or murdered you
would see the heaviness of it the
stories compiled by the native Women's
Resource Center of Toronto executive
director Pamela Hart hand delivered this
massive symbol meant to Spur National
Action to the prime minister's office in
Ottawa to remind him that action needs
to happen quicker and smoother we know
that the number is larger than the four
thousand but we're using the four
thousand because we we want to bring it
back to the action called in the inquiry
report Advocates say a road map on what
to do already exists through those 231
calls for justice in the National
inquiry report which found violence
against this demographic amounts to
genocide
efforts to heal raise awareness and
fight for justice with marches and
vigils on this national day of action
happening right across the country we're
hoping to you know keep it top of mind
for folks as we kind of move through the
process of Truth and Reconciliation
there's always more that we can do
Canadian white women generally ignore us
so that's why it of course it
perpetuates they would rather have their
own voice over our voice and I mean the
foundation to the women's rights to vote
was done on the back of a metis woman
right here in Calgary many say police
are apathetic towards these cases and
discriminate against them forcing
victims families to conduct their own
independent investigations into the
murders of their loved ones assistant
professor Dr Krista stalkaya says
specific recommendations relating to
policing need to be acted on often at
times police come out and kind of start
to blame the lifestyle of victims as
opposed to looking that looking at them
like they are victims of violence and
police really need to start to
interrogate those Notions within their
Force
back in Toronto a commemoration for the
lives lost part of an ongoing call to
action being led by those most affected
by the very disappearances they're
trying to bring to light
Global News
farewell to the queen of country next a
look at Loretta Lynn's Legacy
it would take too long to list all the
awards and accolades Loretta Lynn won
over her trailblazing career she taught
the country music chart 16 times a
singer and songwriter who got her start
as a young woman and never stopped Lynn
died peacefully in her sleep today at
the age of 90. as Eric Sorensen reports
the music world is paying heartfelt
tribute to one of the most beloved
country stars in history
when I was born
she really was a Coal Miner's Daughter
from the hills of Kentucky but she sang
about stories that struck a chord with
country music fans for more than 50
years often the hardships women faced
with their men
[Music]
she married at 15 had six children with
a husband who at times abused alcohol
and her I think you should every day
living I mean I had to live my songs to
write them
[Music]
Loretta Lynn's own heartaches made her
music more relatable
[Music]
her autobiography the Coal Miner's
Daughter inspired the academy
award-winning film woman if you want to
keep that arm you better get it off of
my husband an unvarnished tale of how
her husband's Behavior was the source of
many of her songs but the man she called
Doo pushed her to sing managed her
career and they never split up she gave
me a guitar because I like the way you
sing he said you're going to be a singer
and I and I I sing and I made it
I couldn't let him down
Loretta Lynn sang about birth control
and divorce digging deep into hard
subjects that were banned by some radio
stations till their popularity won out
when it hit the charts they had to take
it out of being banned and and play it
you know everybody had to play it when
it was on the charts Dolly Parton posted
she had millions of fans and I'm one of
them I miss her dearly Miranda Lambert
wrote She blazed so many trails for all
us girls in country music and from Carol
King she was an inspiration
and was the first woman ever to win the
country music association's Entertainer
of the Year later she was given the
presidential medal of freedom and when
she won a Lifetime Achievement Award
Garth Brooks gave her a lift I said you
want me to pick you up in a limo or the
truck she goes bring the truck darling
that was it
she sang with country icons like Conway
Twitty and later in life collaborated
with a new generation of singers like
Jack White
Loretta Lynn will be remembered as a
no-nonsense Storyteller and a resilient
star from humble beginnings
oh my God
[Music]
[Applause]
and tonight's here Canada is a little
known fact about Loretta Lynn she got
her start in a Vancouver neighborhood in
the 1950s a backyard chicken coop stood
on this site it was a popular venue for
local musicians at the time a young
Loretta Lynn visited in 1959 that plaque
is to commemorate that day she performed
in front of some record label Executives
they were impressed they signed her and
the following year released Lynn's first
single I'm A Honky Tonk girl which she
re-recorded for her final 2021 album
that's global national for this Tuesday
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow
my heart was in the world but now I'm a
honky tonker
[Music]